this week the Health Secretary Jeremy
Hunt plashed with Donald Trump no less
on Twitter after the US president has
hacked our National Health Service how
dare he saying it is going broken not
working now mr. hunt responded that he
was proud to be from a country where all
get care no matter the size of their
bank balance but Donald Trump is correct
though not for the reasons he would like
our NHS is failing longer life
expectancy an increased demand has put
the service under great pressure but
successive governments have kicked
fixing the issue into the long grass now
there is a way forward but it takes
political courage we must all contribute
more if we want our NHS to survive and I
reckon the majority of the Nick the
majority of the public is we support
this survey Lamar we mark the 70th
anniversary of the NHS as we do a health
service free at the point of view should
make us all proud but to maintain it we
all have to play our part have I given
my hand away do you see my react so for
the viewers who aren't up to speed with
the with the tweets a bit more reading
aloud from me it starts with one from
President Trump the Democrats are
pushing for universal health care while
thousands of people are marching in the
UK because there you as an universal
health care system is going broken not
working Dems as in Democrats want to
greatly raise taxes for really bad and
non personal medical care no thanks to
which last when I read our promise
Jeremy cut to health secretary responds
I may disagree with claims made on that
March but not one of them wants to live
in a system where 28 million people have
no cover he means in the US NHS may have
challenges but I'm proud to be from the
country that invented universal coverage
we all get care no matter the size of
their bank balance
I had to chuckle as I saw this all go
through because about two months ago
those on the left was saying the NHS is
done for the NHS isn't working the NHS
is on the point of failure it's all and
then of course they're great bogeyman
President Trump comes out and says that
listen well no oh my god how we going to
distance us he was only saying what they
had been saying and he is right let's
say and I'm happy to say he ran out the
NHS has actually saved the life of one
member of my
and I would imagine it's help for each
and every one it is an absolute that it
is the crown jewels it is the biggest
jewel of our crown jewel it is part of
being British however where we part and
I've done a bit of research is fixing
the issue we need to contribute more
magic
it's alright intelligence you like you
to pander a few more quitter there are
people watching this who aren't struggle
street who are on struggle should hold
on one sec hold on what's it policy it's
jack we are speaking in the week in
which most people's council tax will go
up by perhaps about a hundred quid this
is money these folks have to find so
sitting there in your very smart suit I
envy you that when you went on about my
store you've got a lovely suit Oh we'll
pay a bit more no this is what we do
lastly do you know that money that is
wasted in the NHS it's about two and a
half billion pound a week let's just
pause for the viewers two and a half
imagine that pound that's each week and
why is it that because in one instance
we charge fifteen hundred pound for two
pound pot with moisturizer no one ever
does anything waste and another one a
pack of twelve rubber gloves that would
normally cost 35 P is being paid 16
pound 47 there's plenty of money there
we just need to spend it back you talk
about and I completely agree with you
and I can give you some more figures
about the wastage 160 million quid on
you'll see my surgery 1.3 billion on
negligence claims but anyway seven point
six billion on things like expensive
toilet rolls but anyway that's fun about
yeah we keep we all talk about how much
we love the NHS but what every all of us
are guilty of abusing it and we're
guilty because a million missed hospital
appointee na s hang on say eight million
missed hospital appointments every
hospital if I'm across er notice 120
quid that's a billion quid a year nine
million people are sent away from a na
every year with just guidance which
means they didn't have to bother a knee
in the first place they they could have
gone to their local pharmacist that
could have gone to the GP that could
have done one one one and got help in
the systems so you know when we say we
love the NHS if we love it we've got to
stop abusing it and treating a problem
put some context there very theatrical
I've got to say when so the Commonwealth
Fund investigated all the health
services in in Western countries and
they thank you my top ten years in a row
that our NHS came out top four outcomes
but it doesn't mean it's not it doesn't
mean there isn't room for improvement
and that she is because we have such a
robust debate other around it is one of
the reasons my survival rate is working
in terms of percentage of GDP we
actually spend less than the Americans
do on their privatized system the
Americans spent sixteen point six
percent of their GDP and we only spent
nine point ninety percent of our but the
public should this the philosophy just
last thing I promised I'd probably okay
the money you spoke of the money yes
it's a nice suit thank you as a man that
makes the soup what I'd say well I'd say
it's the Baker Commission recommendation
officially that looked into this and
they found that if you add merely one
penny on our national insurance
contributions we could help contribute
to the NHS and eighty three percent of
the public neck it's the pockets of the
public back you wouldn't have to do that
if we stopped the wastage at source and
that's the point if people were a bit
more considerate of the service they
wouldn't be like that feeds into what I
want to say which is about everybody
thinks they will pay for the NHS but
it's free at the point of use it's not
free it's not free we all pay for it and
in our in Germany and in other countries
they have a contribute tree system
whereby you see on your tax return or on
your pay slip how much fourteen percent
twenty percent of this has gone into
your health care system as a result they
have a far more efficient health care
system for example in Germany where you
don't have there isn't a waiting list
you know you have a hospital bed because
people know what they're paying for and
they make they make demands on their
health service therefore the fifteen
hundred moisturizer issue will not arise
in Germany because people are aware of
what they're paying for
and they want value and they demand it
and they get it go to go to Europe they
spend about the same as we do about
eleven percent which is not a lot more
than nine point nine percent on their
health care systems and they don't have
perma crisis
the shop my take on this and I love the
NHS obviously will use it and you know I
want it to continue I wouldn't be
comfortable paying any more money at the
moment towards NHS and that is because I
think that there are structural
inefficiency within the NHS so yes
there's examples of creams and all the
rest of it but I think it's where we're
deeper than this and I think that
somebody needs to have the courage to
say look the NHS currently one of the
biggest if not the biggest employer in
our country we have sir Sir so many
people they're wildly inefficient at
deploying IT services that could add
efficiency for example they've wasted
billions of pounds on failed IT projects
I can assure you at that and actually
what somebody needs to do is have the
courage to pick this thing up and look
at it and go right it was created you
know decades ago what we need to do now
yeah 70 years we need to look at this
system is it still fit for purpose have
we got the right people in the right
places and I personally would argue not
but I would suspect not being an expert
in this I would suspect that what that
would mean is potential redundancies in
back office staff administrative staff
mid mid-level management and I don't
believe there is a politician in the
land that has the courage because it's
alright because yeah I don't think a
politician as well and the lad has the
courage always Lib Dems are saying put
one Pete on national insurance to pay
you know I'm missing my point
I'm saying I don't want to pay any more
until the SIS a lot of people 33 percent
of the country are prepared to pay your
yes will you own a minority and I'm
explaining why I'm worried about my
surgical Bluffs like the EU debate
though for me it doesn't have to be
either/or the EU is inefficient
it is bureaucratic it's red tape laden
but at the same from within
yeah like Westminster we have an i
elected House of Lords doesn't mean we
scrap Parliament right so our NHS may
not necessarily be functioning as
efficiently as it should be but we can
do both we can add a penny to the
national insurance contributions while
making savings else you might not need
to if you structure effectively you
probably won't need to especially
because if no one has ever actually
looked at the inefficiencies and looked
management overall they do this
constantly every successfully because I
can point you to region of Peru to go in
and reform the enemy if anyone's
watching I am available so in that what
you're saying with no 7.6 the
procurement thing is a particularly big
thing this because since the NHS started
they've been buying stuff in the same
way so one Hospital will I had six or
six I'm giving you pay twenty minutes
I'd say the wheelchairs crutches all the
rest of it that is not hard to make if
it's a sorta doesn't have to be a little
bit but also what I think would be
useful if we all get treatment in the
NHS we haven't we know you talked about
it being free it's nothing if all of us
were given a bill not to pay but to show
how much it costs we would give us an
idea and then and then we won't abused
it in future if we tell people it's 120
quid every time you don't bother to turn
up for an appointment and and almost
there twenty percent of all hospital
appointments are wasted because of
people's selfishness because they just
can't pick up the phone